o jogo
[Música]
eu tenho certeza que todos nós temos
algo em comum aqui essas duas fotos ou
na minha infância e não é muito difícil
de minha janela
eu tinha uma vida muito confortável
eu tenho pais que me amam eu tinha casa
tinha estrutura tinha estudo mas eu era
diferente ou na baixinha gordinha
bolsista e negra
tudo começou é graças à chegada do mac
donald's em pelotas sendo a empresa que
mais entende de marketing na face da
terra o macdonald's fomentou em mim o
desejo do mclanche feliz estudantes
bolsistas não têm acesso ao mac lanche
feliz
exceto se uma das colegas de classe a
fizesse o seu aniversário no mês de maio
no mcdonalds com direito a lanche ronald
mcdonald brinquedo e um mac lanche feliz
[Música]
distribuir os convites começou aquele
burburinho eu sabia que a festa é assim
no sábado e eu não fui convidada mas eu
não fui convidado a sozinha eu ea minha
colega partida ficamos de fora porque
não tinha um convite suficiente na
segunda feira começou aquele burburinho
os meus pais causando o caos na escola
diretora sem saber o que fazer
a mãe da criança dizendo que faltava
convite e eu não fui na festa e
continuei sem o mclanche feliz e de
quebra descobriu que era racismo
alguns anos depois vamos aprender sobre
migração no rio grande do sul
a professora de história fez todo aquele
panorama da imigração italiana
eu vi os meus colegas se orgulhando dos
seus passaportes estrangeiros dos seus
vilarejos italianos da sobrevivência ao
holocausto da de saber da sua própria
história e no meu caso
a gente só falou de 13 de maio de
chicotada de sofrimento de foto e poema
de navio negreiro a gente não falou das
minhas cores a gente não falou da minha
áfrica a gente não falou do meu idioma
da tecnologia que meu povo desenvolveu
que o homem começou lá a gente não falou
de nada disse
e ali eu tomei a decisão que eu não
tinha noção da profundidade em algum
momento da minha vida eu ia morar na
áfrica que a gente tem mais de um
continente como um país
mas quando eu fosse eu ia ver pela ótica
dos meus olhos não dos olhos da
professora mas eu continuava bolsista e
o meu pai funcionário público e minha
mãe também me levaram a áfrica que
podiam e com 14 anos eu descobri o meu
dará o meu atabaque a minha cor
a minha áfrica quem eu era e foi na onda
e rodará e no projeto de mãos dadas com
nossas raízes e nossos irmãos que eu
descobri que não era um concurso de miss
que me define que não era um cabelo liso
que ia me incluir que a minha voz tinha
vez e que o meu canto tinha poder e de
quebra descobri que eu poderia mudar o
mundo através das pessoas
e foi assim que eu parei na faculdade de
psicologia
com 17 anos eu fiz cinco vestibulares em
três cidades e tive três fracassos
eu passei para a psicologia numa
universidade particular em primeiro
lugar no último ano em que a
universidade não deu uma bolsa para o
primeiro colocado e foi assim que eu
parei na faculdade de direito
eu costumo dizer que não fui eu que
escolhi o direito foi o direito que me
escolheu
pelo simples fato de que eu não poderia
sacrificar o salário dos meus dois pais
para resolver
o meu sonho como psicóloga e como a
maioria dos jovens negros desse país
eu renunciei o meu sonho e encarei a
realidade mas na faculdade de direito eu
descobri que eu poderia educar e
educadores para evitar episódios de
racismo como os que eu sofri e para
fazer valer uma lei que desde 2003 tenta
tirar a cultura negra do clichê de navio
negreiro sofrimento e dor e trazer essa
cultura e trazer essa cor
e foi no projeto educa que eu desenvolvi
esses projetos e trabalhei com esses
professores mas eu falei pra vocês que
ainda tinha aquele sonho de ir para a
áfrica
aquela áfrica continente
aquela áfrica que tem cor tem calor de
temperatura têm calor humano tinha minha
cultura ea minha história e com 22 anos
eu me tornei diretora de uma ong
moçambique
eu me lembro de cada segundo do processo
de escolha de escolha pela língua do
casaco rosa que eu vestia no inverno
gaúcho e do calor que eu sentir quando
eu pisei naquele lugar das letras
vermelhas do aeroporto de maputo do
sonho que eu tinha de longo prazo de
recuperar a minha vida
depois de um processo de depressão do
brasil foi uma paixão arrebatadora
avassaladora foram dias ótimos mas
paixão nem nem sempre é só coisa boa
e foi num dia de setembro e fica a dica
para todos os meus colegas não mexendo
no celular e caminho na rua que o meu
sonho foi literalmente por bueiro
enquanto eu falava no a tap
eu caí e fraturei o meu tornozelo e com
tragédia nunca vêm sozinhas
eu tinha um tornozelo machucado estava
de cama o meu salário atrasou o meu pai
ficou doente e eu estava vendo a minha
perna embora infeccionada turrona do
jeito que eu sou
demorou para admitir que meu sonho tinha
acabado
demorou para admitir
e aquilo não ia dar certo que era hora
de voltar e eu voltei sem emprego sem
dinheiro com a família fragilizada e uma
perna para recuperar e um trabalho
entregue pela metade
mas como eu tenho mais sorte que juízo
duas semanas depois de pisar de novo no
brasil apareceu a oportunidade que a
mudar minha vida uma empresa global com
um diretor brasileiro no brasil
argentino um líder de área negro eo
gerente maluco suficiente para me levar
de pelotas até são paulo que são mais de
mil quilômetros só para me entrevistar e
como todo bom recém-formado eu estava
fazendo mais de 20 processos e tinha um
especificamente que caía no mesmo dia eu
fui consultar os meus pais para ver o
que eles achavam quanto os dois
processos eu tinha que seguir o meu pai
é um cara muito centrado e respeita
muito as minhas ideias e disse minha
filha já tomou sua decisão com a cabeça
eo guia teu coração já tomou a minha mãe
a arquiteta e no auge da sua sabedoria é
de cimento sempre vendi minha filha mas
eu já tinha tomado uma decisão pela
tecnologia e eu fui pra fazer um ciclo
de quatro entrevistas em são paulo a
primeira entrevista com gerente maluco
que tinha me levado a segunda entrevista
com o líder português que queria levar
trainee para a área de vendas que
ninguém fazia a terceira entrevista com
o rh deixando claro que eu já estava
mais perto do que longe hora da última
entrevista o líder da área que me fez
voar aqueles mil quilômetros para me
entrevistar eu já estava com aquele
sentimento de que já ganhei estava com a
minha melhor roupa de advogado recém
formado um cabelo liso esticado que eu
não uso desde lá
sentei na sala e esperei abre a porta um
negro de 1 metro e 80 com aquele oi
características de uma pessoa que
aprendeu português
passada a olha pra mim e eu travo era
entrevista que a mudar minha vida era
hora de reconstruir o meu sonho não
tinha mais nada a perder e eu travei e
com a sabedoria de quem lida com um
novinho tempo todo ele pergunta o que
aconteceu eu travado no impulso de quem
não pensa antes de falar falei eu nunca
vi um executivo negro na minha vida
e naquele momento eu vi que ele também
não tinha visto jovens negros naquele
ambiente porque depois a gente começou a
construir um projeto que mudou a
realidade de grandes empresas no brasil
aconteceu que a empresa estava num
momento de mudança e eu também
e depois daquela entrevista eu pude
deixar claro quem eu sou a favor da
igualdade de gênero a favor de uma
liderança jovem e muito mas muito focado
e negritude aquele momento me
proporcionou conectar com outras pessoas
e empresas que queriam e tinham como
propósito de vida tornar o mundo
corporativo um pouco mais parecido com o
que tinha da porta pra fora
mas o cenário nunca foi dos mais
favoráveis
só para vocês terem como exemplo hoje
nas 500 maiores empresas do brasil
apenas quatro pontos 6 por cento das
vagas de liderança são ocupadas por
negros como eu lei esse dado é que eu
sendo uma mulher negra tem 10 pontos 4
por cento de chance de ocupar um cargo
de liderança ganhando um quarto do
salário de um homem branco mas ao mesmo
tempo eu tinha uma empresa favorável à
minha proposta
o mercado disposto a escutar e um mundo
de profissionais negros que irão lutar
junto comigo e quando o cenário não é
favorável ou a gente segue a história
que escreveram para a gente
ou a gente constrói uma nova e acho que
ficou muito clara a minha escolha
quem escuta essa história pensa que é um
conto de fadas que está tudo dando certo
mas não eu ainda tenho que provar porque
o piso nesse palco eu ainda tenho que
provar porque eu sou uma executiva eu
ainda tenho que provar por que que eu
falo mais de uma língua porque eu
estudei e por que que eu sou advogada
quando as pessoas perguntam você fez a
prova da ordem
eu queria muito que isso fosse só comigo
porque seria relativamente fácil de
resolver mas ainda não eu vejo os meus
colegas negros trabalhando 14 horas por
dia
renunciando à saúde e ao bem-estar às
famílias para provar que eles podem
ficar ali e que eles são qualificados o
suficiente e foi resposta esse porque a
gente está aqui porque que essa causa
existe que a gente fundou a rede de
profissionais negros a rede veio para
valorizar quem veio antes da gente
a rede veio para inspirar quem veio
depois de nós ea rede veio pra construir
uma jornada junto com as empresas que
estão começando nessa caminhada de
igualdade racial
a gente quer provar com dados fatos e
pessoas que existem profissionais negros
qualificados no mercado
depois de quatro anos de todo esse
roteiro que eu falei pra vocês eu
consegui atingir algumas coisas eu virei
executiva com menos de 30 anos que era o
que eu queria eu sou o líder mulheres do
brasil no grupo de igualdade racial que
é a maior associação de mulheres
política partidária do brasil
eu pude dividir espaço com empresas que
estão começando nessa jornada com maio
ae
a cargill a down a própria microsoft hp
entre outras
e eu pude conhecer organizações que
seguem nesta luta junto com a gente como
e br
a educafro empregue afro feira preta e
muitas outras porque essa jornada ela
não é sozinha e eu fui listado pela
revista forbes como uma das jovens
abaixo de 30 anos que vai mudar a
realidade do brasil e até para quem veio
de pelotas eu acho que eu cheguei muito
longe
a pergunta que eu tenho certeza que está
pairando na cabeça de vocês é como é que
eu vou mudar esse cenário como é que a
gente vai fazer isso e agora é o momento
mais difícil da fala é dividir com vocês
que eu não sei se eu soubesse se eu
tivesse essa receita de bolo eu juro
pela minha vida que eu já tinha feito
algo para sair desse 0.4 por cento
a minha proposta e vamos tentar junto é
acertado errando que a gente vai fazer e
eu tenho alguns passos que a gente pode
começar a fazer junto o meu primeiro
pedido é deixem claro que igualdade
racial é um assunto importante pra vocês
os amigos de vocês a rede com fio no
censo que vocês têm de transformação
o segundo passo é se você tem um colega
negro a poente de feedback mentor em a
existência daquele cara no espaço
daquela mulher é um ato político em
conversa com a organização das empresas
existem políticas de igualdade racial
focadas em um plano de ação diálogo a
gente tem que tá tendo aqui a gente
precisa fazer algo para mudar essa
realidade apóia organizações como as que
eu falei e locais que cuidam de
igualdade racial porque elas estão
lutando para sobreviver
a pergunta também que vem depois dessa
proposta é porque essa menina está
fazendo isso
ela quer ser político ela quer abrir uma
consultoria de diversidade
qual é o motivo com o porquê dela e eu
digo pra vocês o meu porque é inspirar
meninos e meninas como
jeane lá de trás a pensarem que o mundo
corporativo também pode ser delas que
elas podem conquistar aquelas podem sair
de pelotas e que elas podem dominar o
mundo e estar em espaços que nunca
ninguém esteve sendo protagonista da sua
própria história e que eu como executiva
possa ver a cadeira da presidência não
como algo inatingível mas como algo que
pode e eu vou trabalhar muito pra ser
meu
o que a gente precisa
juntos são de oportunidades no mundo
onde 95% dos espaços de liderança são
ocupados por pessoas brancas foram as
pessoas negras que me deram força que me
deram apoio que me deram espiritualidade
e que me colocaram aqui mas foram as
pessoas brancas ou negras que me deram
aquela bolsa de estudo que acreditaram
no meu talento que me deram oportunidade
que me tornaram trainee que me trocar
que me ajudaram a ser a vendedora que eu
sou que me ajudaram também a principal
que dividir essa mensagem com vocês e se
vocês querem saber eu devolvi na mesma
ou em maior proporção
muito obrigada
[Aplausos]